Oakland really will chew up and spit you
out
like I guess nothing you know P we get
killed everyday you know living I hope
nothing Spanish tomorrow you know so if
I'm going tomorrow what legacy would I
leave behind my name is Tyrone Stevenson
also known as baby champ scary white
King and I'm the founder and CEO of the
original schedule I take alright because
it's my lifestyle I don't know it just
makes me express myself even more you
work with you that lives in the
community and teach them how to make
their bicycles for students you know for
kids to be a part of the team you have
to have at least a 2.0 GPA some of them
like it some of them don't but at the
end of the day they have to respect it
if they want to be a part of this team
we use different bike parts to make one
big one and make it look better back
basically fix anything on the bike now
the scary ride team teaches you how to
you know customize your bikes put
aluminum foil and duct tape and spray
paint on the bike and you know make nice
sky every bike is bigger than his life a
regular bike is it's a regular bike I
ride scraper bike because I like the way
they look you get to show it off and say
you made it yourself yesterday was our
grand opening of the shed the first
youth brand bike shop
ever in Oakland I found it the original
scrubber body team officially 2007 my
cousin Avery it's a bittersweet feeling
to open up the show you know just
knowing that my cousin Avery isn't
around you know just to see you know
just to have his presence here because
it was killed it wasn't murder senseless
and I'm gonna doing nothing I feel like
this whole movement is dedicated to him
you know and I do this because one day I
might not be here and somebody else can
step into my place and keep it going
you